so we got a video from jubilee today
titled
do all white folks think the same about
[Music]
race
people have culture
i don't know if like people pretend like
irish and italian people don't exist but
i don't i never understood this question
three
two one
we're all technically white if you're
from england if you're from australia if
you're from
wherever south africa you know we all
have these crazy
places we come from and these people are
around and we get those ideas from those
people
but that doesn't mean us as a whole have
no culture but as a white person
it's not really a culture you can have
culture like i'm hella irish
obviously and that's a culture but that
just being
white is not a it's it's not a culture i
can't relate to you just because you're
white
i think you could say that for any
ethnicity though tell them girl
tell them africans in north americans
don't necessarily see the eye on a lot
there's
cultural differences same thing with
people from the caribbeans and other
parts
so good rebuttal from what but i think
that they're saying the same
somewhat of the same thing but it
results in different views
he strongly disagrees not because white
people don't have culture
but because white
because they're so different types of
white
they're gonna have just one culture
right whereas
she's uh strongly agrees she goes more
on the side of stronger greens
because they're so different therefore
therefore
there's she acknowledges that they're
different cultures you know i mean and
it just proves you that you can
actually say the same things and base
yourself on the same thing
and they're they both internalize it
differently if we were all black
could i relate to you guys if just
because of the color of our skin
yes because they go through very similar
experiences like they'll get
discriminated against and
you're not getting discriminated against
because of your skin color they can both
relate to that
but apparently you do share privilege
isn't that what y'all always say when
y'all get on that liberal you know me we
all got this privilege
but i also feel like with culture we
branch out we try different things we
want to do different things so maybe
we've lost a little bit of our culture
maybe we're creating a new culture there
you go
i believe in reverse racism
[Music]
ugh what's this new term what's pervert
is it just like when a white folks does
something or less yes or like
is white on black reverse
is when white people suffer it's racism
it's not reverse nothing it's still
racism
the reason why i don't like the term
reversalism is because it implies the
idea
that black folks have the institutional
power to be against white people
and they don't so it's not possible it's
not the [ __ ] out of here
i grew up where it was completely like
hispanic culture
i was constantly made fun of because i
was white oh
white people can't dance white people
look stupid whatever
yeah but they're not being they're being
prejudiced
you can't even hold this straight do you
imagine if like a latino person was like
i think white folks are inferior and
someone's like yeah that's not right
that is just prejudice i'm like man if
you don't get the
fatty without bullsh and also frankly
this is part of the definition of racism
i just i hate that stuff but now they're
training they're changing the dictionary
of course definition to fit to fit
whatever narrative to include the
institutional aspect
if i turned around and said black people
can't dance
i'd get hell for that yeah because it's
not true
you you'd get help for it because it's a
lie
three two one
it's crazy how the same three people are
always disagreeing but it's interesting
i think it's important to focus on race
in order to bring us together
there is a race issue in america and if
we just avoid it all together and
pretend like it's not happening
nothing's going to change in my opinion
i kind of was thinking about the
question differently because if all i'm
thinking about when i meet someone is oh
i'm white and she's not white and i'm
white and she's not white like
that's for me that's like what focusing
on races cultural
appropriation is real
three two one
this feels like an interview question
for a job
application at buzzfeed that you
actually don't want like like you know
when you're planning
to buzzfeed and just like so you want to
be the janitor okay great
is cultural appropriation yeah i think
cultural appropriations very well you
see all the time like coachella you know
we're in l.a and you see people
in the native american headdresses
without knowing how
important that is to native people yeah
exactly i think there's a difference
between
respecting the culture and completely
disrespecting the culture
but then also if you want to dress up
and
halloween like a a geisha
because you like the costume you think
it's a beautiful costume
that i wouldn't say is that's the same
that's the same as disrespecting the
culture
this is the same thing i wouldn't do
that i think if you're gonna go and
dress up as a geisha
without knowing the importance of it and
just being like well this
is cute like i'm gonna put this on and
also even if you did know the importance
and you're like
i don't know halloween is just like a
weird holiday to be dressing up as
anybody else's culture you can say the
same thing about
any costume are you gonna tell a
six-year-old girl that she can't dress
up like a pirate because she doesn't
know the history of pirates like
that's very different there's a whole
bunch of somalians being like
i'm dick upton now okay this is
interesting topic i think it can be
disrespectful for sure
if you're wearing something as a
traditional attire for specific
ceremonies and someone's just wearing it
willy-nilly
as like their their goof i could see how
that's
disrespectful you know um
there are certain outfits that are are
worn for ceremonies for rites of passage
right or for example even the military
we're given parade uniforms
right and if i saw a regular civilian
wearing one it would make me feel a
little bit weird seeing him where all
the medals and all that stuff that i'm
not going to tell someone don't do it or
whatever
but i could understand why people would
be like ugh what do you think
yeah i agree okay i'm not gonna do like
her and repeat everything you said
i think it's a lot about intention
because i think wearing that thing at
coachella like
i feel like i would see that as that
person mocking someone
well even if they don't intentionally
mean it it's still offensive
that's true you know your intentions
aren't everything do they matter yes
but the impact also partially matters is
the intention the most important part
yes
but just like i said before you get in
the car you drink and drive you didn't
intend to kill somebody but you still
did
you're still negligent in a dangerous
way i'm not saying that this is akin to
that
but all i'm trying to say is that your
ignorance of the consequences of what
you do
irrespective of your intentions matters
three two one
the only reason i'm at somewhat disagree
is because
a lot of my favorite rappers use it
frequently like if i'm listening to my
favorite childish gambino song which it
drops it like a hundred times
you know it's like i'm not sitting there
thinking all these horrible things about
black people and i'm like
it's just in the song and when i'm
singing
it comes out there's like two different
forms of the word there
ends with an er and with an a
this is a hard video to get through
preach what do you have thoughts
what i'm i'm packing my sh i can
appreciate the fact that they're trying
to make this video to talk about these
things but good lord
this is hard to watch i'm ready to go
bro
you know what i what i don't like about
these videos is like they always just
harp on the super fluid stuff that
really don't matter
can white folks say the n word in
private when they're listening like who
cares
like do i do you think i'd give a sh if
a tree falls in the wood and nobody
hears it
this is what that's that's what that
feels like yes it does you know like i
don't care
and answering that question is not going
to help save lives
yeah it's not gonna get people not
killed by it because
you know these are the police didn't say
the n word in front of a black man
therefore the black man was dead
that's not what happened yeah that's not
where the problem is so
you know what i realized watching this i
think when it comes to these issues and
and
black folks specifically i think i just
get bored of always hearing about the
same topics
yeah it's always the same stuff can we
say that we're like that's not what's
really hurting us
you know until we start talking about
class more often and finances
all this other is really irrelevant yeah
i don't care about the n word i don't
yeah i don't do you think jewish people
care if you use
whatever jewish they don't care man like
with my friends they're like oh you can
say it with an
a like that won't hurt my feelings but
also
like even when i'm in the car by myself
like i still
feel like it's not my place maybe i'll
like whisper it like with an a
at the end you know like i can't i'm
sorry guys i know you guys wanted this
video but it's just like
these discussions they're not interested
you answering all these questions
doesn't solve the problem that's what
exactly you said
you talked about okay why people say the
n-word it's not the issue
it is not and so even cringe you're
watching yeah
it's just cringy it's just cringy yeah
it's just crazy yeah i just feel like
people focus these discussions
on this topic in the wrong place it
isn't helping we have a huge class
problem
you know like we need to talk about
other things we've been talking about
this topic forever
who cares it's not that important so
that's my thoughts on this um i don't
think jubilee did a bad thing i think it
just
kind of repeated a lot of the questions
that people have been asking themselves
forever and
and these are dumb questions to be
honest with you that's what i think
that's what i think i just think that is
i think
i think it's just easier to talk about
these questions because they're more in
your face and they're more apparent
they're more flagrant
but the real issues that are affecting
minority communities don't get discussed
because they're not an easy enemy to
look at
yeah exactly why people say to edward
and
with everything that happened all right
with everything that happened in the
history yeah why people saying that
we're a man and now that person is the
evil but that does not solve
anything let me give you a good example
2015 we had a giant case
uh where i think the department of
justice got 200 million dollars from a
bank
because they were found out to be
redlining practice that was eliminated
in the 60s
was still happening today if you don't
know what ted redlining is when they bar
people from having access to loans
and things like that because of where
they live at and also race
majority of their visitors yeah so they
got the settlement done they found out
to be guilty of redlining
and what strikes me as interesting is
that if
there was more upward mobility if
people's financial situations were
better
a lot of these issues that we're dealing
with today wouldn't exist
you know that's also something to
recognize if george floyd lived in a
much richer neighborhood
i don't think that that situation would
have happened and
it sounds like a direct correlation
that's too crazy to make but what i'm
trying to say is that
a lot of us are living in bad areas
forced by all kinds of issues that
happen at the top
right and we're
so focused on like did she say the n
word not recognizing that this thing is
way bigger 200 million
is a huge settlement to be accused of
redlining is a big deal
but it's not as discussed as someone
being arrested on tape because the
visual of it is not as impactful
we have a culprit but it doesn't mean
that this is not more important
you know the documentary on the 13th and
how it talks about the 13th amendment
how it functions
that's way more important to discuss
than whether someone else could so i
just think sometimes when we focus the
discussion on like
i want to be epithet towards black folks
i'm like whoa i feel like we're
discussing
the wrong things that's all yeah so
anyways let us know what your thoughts
are did you feel like we should have
kept going with the video
we're not going back so it doesn't
matter yeah but let us know we're not
going to finish the video if you
want to see it so you can answer
but i mean we're not gonna you know the
only problem i have with these kind of
things is like
range of beliefs but you also have to
understand they're pulling everyone from
the same area
it's not like you can people bring
people from across the country to share
in on this
generally speaking so
it's white folks in that area doesn't
mean that they're
a monolith either but it does cloud your
it does form your your experience it's
like if i did a video with black folks
in new york it's not gonna be the same
as if i did in florida
louisiana texas or the west coast it's
going to be a different experience
then again i don't really necessarily
agree that you're going to have a
different answer because
like the borrowers are so different and
you got different grades of what like it
depends what
black people you're going to get you're
going to get black people from the from
hoods from different uh
social class so it might be actually
different you know what i mean
but i i digress well i mean just take
for example voting blocks and principles
people vote differently based off where
you live
you know black folks necessarily in
specific states don't vote the same as
another
same with white folks white folks in the
south don't vote the same as white folks
generally speaking
in the west or up north yeah so so of
course
like even here quebec we're different
than most of canada
and you feel that when you talk to other
canadians i feel that drastically
absolutely
true so you're right yeah your area is
obviously